can you can you pull out that video
can you pull up that video that kamala
harris shared yesterday
or two days ago that got six seven
million views that probably wasn't the
best timing
i'm a byproduct of escape in iran to
come here because of that video just so
you know i don't know if you saw that
video or not
have you seen the video have you seen
kamala's video there's not a vc pitch
so there's a big difference between
equality and equity here we go equality
suggests
oh everyone should get the same amount
the problem with that
not everybody's starting out from the
same place so if we're all getting the
same amount but you started out back
there and i started out over here
we could get the same amount but you
still gonna be that far back behind me
it's about giving people the resources
and the support they need
so that everyone can be on equal footing
and then compete
on equal footing equitable treatment
means we all end up at the same place
i'm getting emotional watching this it's
a tearjerker
what do you think about this video it
looks like it was made for
five-year-olds
what do you think about this video when
you see this adam there's a big
difference between the quality of life
can you pause it is it really no i don't
know
i i can't understand why was it made
like what was what was the point what
she's trying to say is that socialism
yeah i get what she's trying to say but
i'm like right now
i mean i don't know when socialism
that's how you process this i didn't
think okay no we get we get our
nicknames
it's a little different because what i
mean i understand what she's trying to
say of course that
if if you're track i mean let's just
call it what it is
if i start in the hood and you started
in the suburbs
you're probably going to get to where
you're trying to go as far as success
if you're going to measure success on
that as far as success-wise if we both
were given the same resources
you started in the penthouse i started
in the projects
that's that's pretty much what you're
saying that's what she's saying that's
how i took it
that's what she said she's she's saying
that there's no where you're safe
some people will say oh no there's
there's
it's not happening you know everybody
starts on the same foot everybody goes
out and
work the same if you work hard you're
going to be successful
that's not always true it's a lot more i
disagree
i know you disagree with that because
because you can't
but here's what i'm saying but but
here's the thing though
it's all about your mindset it's all
about your mindset
and when what she said and that or what
she
i'm assuming what she was trying to say
i would have approached it in that
manner just if your mind has been
tampered with
for so long and then you finally get out
and they give you the same resources
you're probably not going to end up the
same way i can work 19 times harder than
you
sometimes it just doesn't work out that
way but for the few it will
for the future it will everybody's not
going to get
where you got to because of work ethic i
mean i know guys that
i know guys that will work all day all
night they're still not going to get
oh no i don't disagree with that but i
don't think that's the only on the area
though
i don't know i agree i think i think
i think at the end of the day to give a
message like that it's
it's to me it's a divisive message
because for me look
everybody has the same amount of hours
per week i can pick and choose to watch
tv when i get home i can pick and choose
to pick up a book
i can pick and choose to go home and
play video games i can pick and choose
to learn how to sell and learn a new
skill set i can pick and choose to go
and watch sports online log on i can
pick and choose
to start a side business i have that
choice yep and i don't i don't bind to
uh
of course you you can pick and choose
certain things but
just like it's just like me being a
professional football player
a lot had to go right for me to end up
yeah including the work really i think
you should be offended by what she said
to be honest with you because what she's
saying
is it goes against everything that this
country stands for
meaning let's all get to the same place
and if you
don't have a certain advantage well
we'll take from the people that have it
we'll bring it down here so we can all
be here get that out of there yeah this
is your project
what was your predominant area growing
up
i'm from l.a you're from the okay we
watched in california
kamala harris changing incarceration
rules
this is not a trump talking point it's
real she changed the rules it's bad
right it says and that's and that's why
crack and powder had penalty like
crack had this kind of penalty yeah
powder had this penalty
you know that's all you know that's
that's absolutely discriminate
just yeah because we're not doing the
powder what are we doing the crack
we know because we can't afford the
powder that's five bucks on the pipe
yeah that's right
80 bucks 80 bucks no doubt no doubt and
so
that's that's why but that's a good idea
can do laps around everybody at this
table regarding topic of marijuana if
you want to
we're not going to that's why that's why
i was saying pbd that i said
i have you know my differences because
of
that part of her so now
she comes you know now it's a whole
different thing that she's come so that
it's kind of double talking to me so
it's hard for me to listen if you know
that early part because she definitely
wasn't saying those things
again i start from the starting point
that she's the most liberal
senator in in the senate so you've got
to read between the lines of everything
she's trying to say she is trying to
push it towards a socialist
communist regime basically that's what
she wants
i think that she i think that she
especially with this message she is
surfing
on a wave of cosmic hypocrisy
that i can't even i can't even swallow
it
okay because she
will come out with something like this
and she'll rant and rave about how we
need to invest in our minority
communities which we need to do but she
didn't think about that
when she incarcerated thousands of
people
for trivial crimes exactly and so this
is what i'm talking about is
we the the media makes it so hard for
you to actually
research the the validity
of a candidate and i'm so sorry we can
say what we want about trump god he's a
buffoon sometimes
but kamala harris is not a friend
to the african-american community she is
not yeah i i did a i did an ig live
thursday and i said what do you think
about uh
you know what's going on and we had
people there from iran haiti
philippines um el salvador and all
we said to answer that ad we have a
great resource
united states of america that's the
resource and just depends on how you use
this resource the
you know the access the information the
access to a lot of the programs
and now to be honest it's a lot
i would i would definitely look at that
now in this day and age i would look at
it and say
i don't agree with that and a lot of it
because of what you can do now with
social media but they've got so many
people believing that they need a hand
out to get a hand up
and see that and most of that i feel
once again
i go back to what i said earlier because
i feel that's political talk
that's politician look at okay what do
you think they want to hear
and let's run that exactly so patrick
as an entrepreneur do you not feel like
your
obstacles make you better at what you do
no question about it
i think the biggest thing is just the
distractions what i had a choice on what
to do with my time and by the way
this is coming from a guy ask and i
intentionally
i was so glad that day my sister decided
to work with
us and php and she's one of our vice
presidents out of southern california
shout out to
my sister paula and siamax kingdom
builders they do great
i'm very proud of those guys but you
know when paulette came
i told everybody go talk to my sister
about who i used to be
i said go talk to and i said paula tell
him everything i'm totally fine with
that
and she said you sure i said just pretty
much everything
because what people needed to know was
what i did
every day i was at a nightclub in the
army
i drank a bottle of tequila every single
week on a saturday on friday saturday
i finished one our buddies would go
finish one then we go straight to
nashville tennessee
either mix factory connections or some
silver silverado told on how to dance
country
i partied every night i could care less
about books first time i ever finished
the book i was 21 years old i
never finished a book cover to cover
until i was 21 years old
never so i don't use my time wisely and
then one time my dad has a heart attack
i go to the hospital ucla medical center
i see him i go down to my car next day i
said it's over with i'm not going to
live this life
from that next day i said don't call me
to the nightclubs i'm not coming to the
nightclubs i'm not coming to the parties
i don't want to do nothing with you guys
they said we don't believe you i said
try me
six months nothing they stopped calling
me and in my life changed i made a
decision to go a different direction
and i had everything around me special k
lsd
ecstasy cocaine heroin pot
you name it every single thing was
around me i made i made a decision to go
to different
parents got a divorce my parents got a
divorce twice
all of these things you add up together
i refuse to buy into you feeling sorry
for me the biggest
offense i take when somebody feels sorry
for me i didn't
you know the whole thanksgiving people
would bring you stuff and it's all poor
patrick i don't
ever don't ever worry that's that's your
seat i mean i love that don't get me
wrong
but that's once again that's your
mindset that's a minds
i mean i disagree i disagree because
everybody doesn't let me let me are you
are you a man of faith
are you manifest okay so man of faith
god god the story about the talents
is that a new story it's a 2 000 year
story what's the story about
yeah just find out why anybody has a
different talent okay but
he gave everybody something god if you
believe in god you believe in free will
yeah
freedom to choose right right kamala
harris doesn't believe in freedom to
choose
kamala harris believes that you're
saying and that's what you did
what i'm trying to say is if you believe
in god and i believe in god and say 41
of america believes in god okay let's
just say christian now i just god a lot
of them believe in god but a
different god let's just say 41
christians and he said
you have the freedom to choose you
have the free will to do what you want
to do you can make good or bad choices
right so what are we going to do now
you're going to rate me based on
not holding me accountable to my bad
choice not my bad choices i
chose to make bad choices it's not on
you
unfortunately accountability the
difference between an
rfk or a jfk and a kamala harris or joe
biden today's the following
a jfk said stop asking what your country
can do for you
today they're saying ask what your
country can do for you
it's flip is
i went to boston when i'm in boston i
went to the john f kennedy museum when
you go into the john f kennedy museum by
the way if you've not been you have to
go to sorry
you go to the john f kennedy so all the
back problems this guy had
growing up as a kid nobody thought he
was going to do anything he was always
joseph he went to war he was a pilot
joseph gets killed that is
devastated anxiety panic attack
depression the father no one thinks
john f kennedy is going to do anything
and then one day john f kennedy decides
to run
and he becomes a president when you go
there you know what was the most
interesting about john f kennedy
how many different countries around the
world loved john f kennedy
how many different countries around the
world created their own museum
just as a shout out to say listen man we
respect you we love you other countries
not paid for by america not a george
bush library here in dallas not a
you know john f kennedy library in
boston what's the point
there's a very big difference between
the democratic party
of 1960s 1970s and even 80s versus 2020.
very different you know i said with the
guys in my company you you know what
company i run
you know exactly what i do we've sat
down the first time we sat down on five
guys
when we started talking that's how you
and i made the connection and that it
led to all these other things that we've
done together
in our company i'm from iran okay
we are 54 latino we are 18
african-american we are 51 women
we are i don't know what are the stats
to give you we sit down and we talk
so what are you for one percent filipino
you know what's crazy
we now have multiple executives in the
company that are gay
and lesbian multiple multiple gay and
lesbian
we have a lesbian couple that's hardcore
christian
that they get treated royally we don't
sit there and judge you
at all we welcome you come on down let's
go take over the world together we don't
have any issues against you
moral the story there's a democratic
party of john f kennedy
and there's the democratic socialist
party of today
where let us solve all your problems for
you i don't i don't agree with that
i don't agree with that but that's the
political system that's what kamala
harris said and that's the politician's
side
that's what's important that's what did
i tell you
the last time we talked about it they
will say whatever the hell they want to
say
i don't believe half of us and that's
where that's where
the problem is the problem becomes this
trump has shown us
we're not guessing he we know what he's
about and what he's going to do and how
he operates
over these last four years so is that a
positive or negative
it could be both it depends on who you
are depends on who you are and what you
like
if you like it that way it's a positive
number sounds like their game
exactly but what about the economy and
things like that i mean look at the
economy yes
but you have to go back and some of the
stuff that trump is saying like he's
saying all he's done for the blacks and
this that and the other
some of that stuff he shouldn't even say
like are you saying it's not true
some of it's not true but are you saying
that trump is not the
racist person abe lincoln is coming to
get him right
he's on the flight if he mentions my
name one more time
when i saw him today when he said
something i mean i'll be the first to
say today he said
you know i have to tell you i've been
the greatest president for
african-americans since abraham lincoln
and some i have to say that because out
of respect some even say i'm better than
abraham lincoln
but i have so he does those things which
is a little bit i
and by the way
i don't disagree with you with that part
i don't but i cannot
stand a philosophy that tells me poor
you patrick
yeah this is why they need us yes let me
give a shout out to a couple people one
guy here funa said
uh that he guarantees trump wears uh
superman wears trump uh underwear is
what he says
so coach constantine costa said
25 car i think she's doing a shout out
for business we got patrick is so right
i don't know which point
i missed the the raising what what are
we you said 25
i keep hearing these numbers these
people are donating
i'm calling by the way if somebody picks
up let's see if we got him on speaker
i'm not putting
it on speaker okay so i'm going to call
ricky ricky if you're ready ricky you're
getting a call
ricky's about to get a call and i think
he has some uh some thoughts for our
friends here
i don't know uh uh i don't think ray
you've ever met ricky before
drinking in california ricky is uh uh
he may be in michoacan let's raise the
audio a little bit
ricky
what do you think about what's being
said right now with ray crockett with
adam with tom
jarrah sapala what's on your mind
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna be honest
with you but if i could be honest with
you
without due respect to the professional
football player that you have in front
of you
uh you know i'm a little bit uh i'm a
little bit disappointed because
you know as a as a kid that grew up
watching sports
and listening to you know watching
and watching all the boxers that we
admire i would i would hate to hear the
message that
what depends where you come from um it
depends where you come from
if you're gonna make it or not it's a
very disappointing message
from a kid that grew up on the hood that
wants to aspire to be somebody because
now what you're saying is
oh i can only make it if the
circumstances are perfect i can only
make it if
if everything is lined up for me it's
because i got lucky
that takes my chances of of of a success
away
and that's what that that's that's the
issue right now like you said
that the issue is not red or blue
democrat or republican the issue is that
one that one government is trying to
here you go here you go you're an able
you're incapable i come from a family in
mexico
you know where we're from i call that
one of the most dangerous parts of
mexico
in the world in mexico and mexico the
most dangerous part
my family migrated here my dad had five
businesses with no
he had no uh he didn't speak english he
was 28 years old and he had absolutely
no papers
i mean we don't we didn't grow up to be
victims we didn't grow up with handouts
so to be told that we can only do things
or make things happen if things are
lined up for us
it's just very disappointing to hear and
on top of that you know that's why
i don't buy it to socialism hispanics
are naturally conservative
hispanics naturally we want to work hard
we love our country
we love god we love our families and we
don't want handouts
but now what happens if you have a
government that's saying we're going to
give you this we're going to give you
that we're going to give you this why
are people subscribing to that
why are we being told that we can't do
something by ourselves that we have to
that we are forced to meet somebody i
don't need anybody i'm a grown man
i don't need another man to hand me
something out i don't need another woman
to hand me something out
why can't i be trust my abilities why
can't i trust my challenge my god-given
talents
the bible says that god made me unique
god the bible says that god made me who
i am as a man
i agree why should i have to depend on
another man well i think too i think
if you look look at more so where she
was trying to go with this i don't think
she was more so trying to say
and that's why i said the commercial was
bad because it wasn't
explained enough it just wasn't enough
explanation but if you go back and you
look at the home situation of
buying homes first time buy our homes
and all this stuff with hood and
all the ways that they try to bamboozle
us and not
allow us to buy homes and things that's
that's what she's talking about when
she's saying stan you know start out
equally
you know they only give out ten percent
of of the loans and
they don't go to you know she wasn't
gearing that commercial with the black
community
i mean that no i mean i think she was
just gearing it in general
tom here's the thing by the way just fyi
give me a second when ricky
speaks when you guys talk even into your
mics you're whispering they're picking
it up so don't say anything when the
phone call is speaking and we'll respond
back to ricky go ahead ricky but
but here's the thing though tom uh you
know here's the thing though
she represents the party that literally
owned the slaves
she represent represents the party that
out that i'll be
they they supported the ku klux klan
that supported jim crow
the party's never switched it's a myth
it's a lie it never happened there's no
proof of it
that she supports the party that uh lbj
created this uh created this program
that incentivized father absence
if that's part of the party she's a part
of and on top of that
i mean if you're gonna sit there and say
oh wait you know
poor you poor you will of course poor me
because you created a system
if anybody created the systematic
oppression it was them
so to sit there trying to say like
you're gonna be like you're you're the
one that shot me now you're gonna come
and put a
band-aid over me you know you're gonna
try to cure me no
get out of my way give me opportunity
don't try to be my savior when you're
the one that shot me you hunted me now
and now you want to pretend like you're
going to save me on top of that don't
buy it in 1977
he was against integration and he wanted
segregation
i mean this is a this is the same man
that pushed the crime by the mass
incarcerated blacks
yeah if trump just signed the first step
back to release four thousand prisoners
eighty-five percent of them be black i
mean if we're gonna look into the
history of this party
and we're gonna look into this message
why can't we see past the [ __ ]
why can't we be seen past the hypocrisy
because if you think that's all it is
it lies in the hypocrisy the same states
that keep voting blue
continue to be the states of the 10
worst cities in the country
are democrat cities and the people keep
voting the same way
why there's got to be a change stop
telling me i can't make it
get out of my way let me use capitalism
free enterprise
and the free market system so get where
i need to get you stop telling me that i
don't even hear that i can't make it
i don't really hear the circumstances
need to be perfect i don't even hear
that like that
that was that i was screwed over 50
years ago that has nothing to do with my
choices right now
it has nothing to do with who i am as a
man right now you know if we're going to
talk about that
the spaniards came and took the the gold
from the mayans and the aztecs
they took a thousand years ago they come
and wipe us out to change our religion
and kill our leaders
rape our women took our gold what am i
gonna do cry about what happened a
thousand years ago and
all of a sudden generationally wounded
because i had post-traumatic stress
disorder because of something that
happened a thousand years ago
yeah and the problem with that is just
like i told pbd
it's really a mental thing at the end of
the day
you have to as a man woman whatever you
have to decide and make your mind up as
to what you want and what you want to be
without expecting any handouts at all
the harder you work things are going to
come your way anyway i believe that i
believe you'll work yourself into a good
situation
what's going to happen when she gets
some real power but here's the thing
though you got to understand this
this is what politicians do this is what
they've been doing
get clear yeah to get in
we just watched robert kennedy give a
talk this is not
this is today's politicians
if you want to say today's politician i
agree i don't think this is
well you're going back but i'm saying
today i agree
yes yeah okay we're on the same page as
far as i can remember
that's what they've done you know even
even malcolm x warned us in the 1950s he
did he did
he warned us about the liberals he told
us the white liberal is deceiving now
the liberals are now
black white and mexican that the
demographics change but the reality is
the liberal has never changed they've
always been the same way
malcolm x wardens in the 50s before they
killed him so if the reality is nothing
you're right nothing has changed because
it's the same people deceiving us
and we keep falling for the same
[ __ ] every time and they keep
flip-flopping
so ricky tell us who's winning tonight
trump 2020
how did i know you were about to say
that
ricky we'll talk to you later tonight
take care buddy
[Music]